oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you bad [ __ ] you
thought it was gonna be a regular monday
church [ __ ] that [ __ ] we're throwing
heat like the corinthians are you
[ __ ] kidding me or what
labor day week we ain't [ __ ] around
here tom segura is in house stop
wiggling me what's the problem what
what's i what's the problem is you give
me a brownie and i have about five
minutes to get everything get my brownie
and i got yeah you're [ __ ] this this
is a way of [ __ ] life this brownie
made me puke on friday the other night i
gave him the whole [ __ ] thing where
he listen he couldn't sleep i can't
sleep okay let's go get you a little
[ __ ] edible so we went over and we
got the uh
so kind the brownie collection right let
me tell you something
this [ __ ] is what they give you like
let's say you get shot eight times and
you won't die
they'll just give you this at the
hospital it's over for you
you'll just bleed the [ __ ] out big [ __ ]
you say him you tell you're saying this
now but everything you give me is seven
milligrams oh yeah this is six this is
six milligrams
it was 33 in the third like john george
harrison that
dad made him puke oh my god the whole
thing he ate the whole thing like a
[ __ ] animal i ate the whole thing
i kept calling them we're going out late
we're gonna [ __ ] see the town at
first okay hold me back i'll be here
like 10 minutes later lee what's up you
ready to go [ __ ] i'm feeling
[ __ ] up right so i know he's going
down
i call him back like in 10 minutes he's
eating sushi so yeah he goes you know
mom
i'm getting a little [ __ ] up all right
i give him another 30 minutes i call him
back he called me like eight times in
one night and also he's like hello
i'm [ __ ] up how much was in this thing
i can't [ __ ] believe how [ __ ] up i
am i'm like [ __ ] it get dressed we're
going out [ __ ] i'm gonna hang up
on him
right and i'm like oh i know and i
called him back and he's like hey the
phone rang like eight times yeah he
picked it up and i'm like where are you
i just puked
i'm so [ __ ] high don't blame it on
the weed it's that wholesale [ __ ]
sushi you got from that area
he goes to this arabian boy
yes you do you told me they got a dummy
with [ __ ] hummus on it or something
[ __ ]
he does he goes to a wholesale [ __ ]
skates eight rolls for three dollars
yeah you're gonna [ __ ] die that's
like suicide it wasn't gas stations it's
good sushi but okay so i was watching a
movie in my on my living room couch and
i made it to the bedroom and i was
laying with my head by the foot and i
just flipped and you even know like when
you're gonna puke like as soon as i
flipped over i was like that's not gonna
happen but i i was able to get off my
bedside and puke on the bed but like
right next to the on the floor
and you can see all the little sushi
bits it was terrible oh my god
you nasty [ __ ]
i've never had to clean up puke high it
was not fun i kept calling him back get
up [ __ ] we're going down we got
more edibles i can't i can't i already
picked the [ __ ]
leaves as tough as [ __ ] nails oh he's
my dog i told him we got animal
tranquilizers tonight is the pre-surgery
show [ __ ] i go in tomorrow lee
picks me up at what time 4 45 45. 4 45
in the morning i get admitted at 5 15
they're cutting me open at seven my
wife's picking me up at 10. beautiful
that's it that's your phone and i'm home
and then you're taking pills and then
i'm taking pills
i got she went food shopping today she
turned everything around so the baby
don't jump on my [ __ ] leg
and that's it i go in tomorrow they hit
me with an iv i talk to them don't have
to shave nothing
are they uh are you getting knees scoped
are you getting meniscus arthritis
they're fixing this little tear on the
side i don't know what it's called
and i go home i'm home for four [ __ ]
weeks i go to bray on the 18th nice and
i go to new york on the 25th new york or
something like that yeah what are you
doing in new york gotham nice tremendous
the 11 45 show like a soldier just one
one show a night
one show how many friday is saturday
that's it that's it 11 45 that's the
[ __ ] way to do it that's the way to
do it i ain't got time to be dilly dally
what else thompson girl you bad
[ __ ] look at you man look at you
where were you last week philly
how hot was it [ __ ]
the basement yeah the club was [ __ ]
literally a hot it's like a [ __ ]
sauna the club is great it's an amazing
club it's an amazing club the food is
great the people that come from
affiliates the shows are awesome the
shows are always awesome the guy is a
great guy but he's jewish he won't fix
the air conditioner you know how jews
feel about fixing the air conditioner
that's a big investment in case we got
to burn the joint down you ever see a
jew after he burns the joint with a new
air conditioner he goes [ __ ] ape [ __ ]
he'd rather be tied up and somebody take
his atm card and rip up his 20s you
understand me
i was thinking of tying him up in ahri
and taking their atm card and every time
a 20 comes out just rip it one at a time
how much does it upset you to fix uh air
conditioning lee
uh if i had to pay for it piss me off
but i mean if i owned a club i think i'd
pay for it but listen a jewish person
let's say a jewish person has to buy new
air conditioning for a building a jewish
landlord he will milk that [ __ ] those
days
he will milk it if he could get eight
months out of tomorrow
he should be here they're sending it
from japan i don't know what happened
let me call hector have you heard from
me
the train got robbed if he could [ __ ]
by the way we're speaking about jewish
here i got this [ __ ] facebook today
about lee about the flag listen let me
explain something to you people it's a
[ __ ] israeli flag if you people get
upset about an israeli flag lee is a
harmless [ __ ] jew he doesn't even
have any malice in his
lee people are upset about it yeah they
might take the [ __ ] or some [ __ ]
jericho who has nothing
to do with his life anybody knows our
intentions are good there's an american
flag there also nobody complains about
that there's a picture of charles
bronson there and there's a [ __ ]
picture clearly so you know what this
spells in here balls
so
don't be upset it's just a [ __ ]
flight you're gonna be mad let me get
the [ __ ] out not even in that shot
either yeah what the [ __ ] is wrong with
people people want a [ __ ] at something
every day there's a free [ __ ] service
yeah nobody bothers you nobody makes you
do nothing you don't have to sign
nothing you have to do [ __ ] dick and
i can't believe how much people [ __ ]
complain
i got a complaint i got a complaint this
weekend in an email a guy said that he
saw my special
and he was enjoying it until
the part where i talk about disabled
people
and he was like because
because he has ms
and he was like and then you made me
feel badly
about it and i was like yeah but
you're choosing to feel badly like
because other people with disabilities
have come up to me and like said how
they had a good time and they laughed at
it because it's a joke you have to think
about intent what's the intent
and he was like no i'm not choosing to
feel that way and i was like yes you are
you're choosing to be upset and you want
to you know you want to go off on
somebody about it but that's your choice
you're choosing to do that they'll
probably go to the barber shop and talk
about it yeah you know those are the
kind of people that they get enthralled
in it
and you're like i don't understand this
all you have to do is switch the channel
yeah exactly that's it the [ __ ] thing
is offend to get in
it's a five dollars you waste five
dollars on that [ __ ] you either [ __ ]
mcdonald's just what's the [ __ ]
channel what do you give a [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying people always gotta get
and these americans all of a sudden it's
a it's a
i gotta tell you last night i was
sitting there i answered the emails
i was had the baby in the living room
after dinner we don't put cartoons on
you do not no because we wanted to
wind down uh [ __ ] play you know okay
write and play with her toys so i got a
chance to scroll to the tv and i got the
chance to watch
like
seven minutes of vmas
oh boy what has happened to society what
has happened to music
music is at an all-time low
and they all sit together like rihanna
and the [ __ ] kardashians and all
these people sit together like they all
love each other and they down inside
they hate each other yeah then beyonce
you know everybody in the world is
saying they're getting [ __ ] divorced
this is the and awesome they're on there
she comes out with the baby and i i told
my wife i go i don't even want i don't
believe we live in such a fantasy
[ __ ] land
i want to know the cameras that they're
putting in as they go away from the
camera you know that hallway you have to
go into
that's where i want the cameras to see
her turn around and go [ __ ] you black
[ __ ] give me that
you [ __ ] my sister you nasty [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what i wanted to see
not that smile and the fake [ __ ] tear
you know it's such a [ __ ] fake
situation miley cyrus i love that dirty
[ __ ] right i love it till last night
the thing with the homeless little kid
what'd she do with the homeless she sent
some homeless little half a [ __ ] up there
to say that you know
hollywood makes 8 billion and there's a
thousand 30 [ __ ] kids on the street
you know what i was in the [ __ ]
street because it was my choice and so
are you you want to run away from your
[ __ ] house because your dad won't let
you go to the [ __ ] prom or whatever
the [ __ ] do you see him you see a little
i heard about it he was a half a [ __ ]
like homo
i don't even know and she's in the back
crying you know jumping up and [ __ ]
down and people comparing it to marlon
brandon marlon brando did something from
his heart not because he was gonna be on
tmz yeah it was 1970 something it wasn't
because he did it to impress people
because marlon brando was really [ __ ]
crazy he was really [ __ ] crazy did
you hear what people are going crazy
tonight about what sarah silverman
brought like thc drops on the like the
emmy red carpet and everyone's saying
it's so amazing i just i i thought of
you like she probably like the dropper
of the drops and and was giving them the
people no she took it out like like an
interview apparently i didn't see it
because i was here but i just i just
thought
i just thought of joey like
like oh my god
look at her she's so cool with the
reefer oh my god on abc with a vapor
pack or something that's what it was it
was a paper bag well i didn't see it
it's amazing that miley cyrus is
terrible man that that the
the uh they did that that profile on her
was like a documentary and they were
like
you're making such bold decisions like
you're so bold and like
and then they go what you do she was
like yeah i mean the thing is like you
just can't care about what somebody
thinks
and he's like okay and that's that's her
mantra and then
they then the music has nothing to do
with that it's just like it's just
totally overproduced [ __ ] like it's
there's no like
actual musical talent involved in what
we're watching we're just watching you
know music is to the point where there's
nobody really doing live music they're
all putting tracks on and it's society
these young kids that pay for that [ __ ]
yeah and they go and they feed that [ __ ]
300 for that [ __ ] blonde and
in uh vegas you know whatever the name
is britain yeah britney spears that's
300 bucks you go to vegas go online see
what the tickets are for britney spears
in las vegas they ain't no 22.50 i tell
you that
all right she's got a residency there i
think it's a three bills three [ __ ]
bills and you know she's going to lip
sync and you still continue to pay it so
whose fault is that you know david grow
has like a big beef with music today i
don't know i read little excerpts he's
mad at the the music that they have on
that show where people judge you
you know whatever that not the view but
the other [ __ ] one i don't know the
one about singing
the voice the voice i know he had a big
then i read an article about three
months ago and then josh wolfe was
saying he had a conversation with dave
grohl and dave grove was saying the same
thing that you want me to tell you
what's really missing from music
drugs
do you think heroin yeah it's got to
make a comeback for these [ __ ] be
real they showed some band last night
these guys have never even [ __ ] drank
club soda
and that's why they're so uptight listen
when guns are stale and boring yeah oh
boring you've heard this [ __ ] before
music is [ __ ] horrible it is [ __ ]
horrible i try to listen to like the
of the [ __ ] and the rap is [ __ ]
horrible and that urban [ __ ] is [ __ ]
horrible and i grew up on everything i
grew up on country i grew up on soul
music i grew up on black music i grew up
on [ __ ] spanish music and i tell you
it's that spanish rep
oh [ __ ] no wonder those mexicans are
shooting each other that is horrific
that is her what is that called pitbull
no oh
what is he [ __ ] saying where's his
[ __ ] stuff
it's [ __ ] terrible that [ __ ] and i'm
spanish i go to miami bro and i want to
shoot myself why the young the new breed
the reggaeton and all that [ __ ]
come on we were we were doing quaaludes
at a [ __ ] club [ __ ] standing there
holding the wall what reagan [ __ ]
dunk oh please they do need heroin again
they are you know guns no they need it
they needed them they needed music again
it's those guys would do
imagine this when they were on they were
on world tours at one point for like
like three years in a row like they
didn't [ __ ] stop touring the world
for a few years guns and roses you
remember like and like that appetite for
destruction and the next album they
would just tour the world
yes they would tour the world and then
tour the world again and they were
drinking like a handle of [ __ ] jack
every night each guy
each guy was [ __ ] just
absolutely brought to grammy awards on
abc you should have seen them they
[ __ ] they were [ __ ]
up they were always [ __ ] up on heroin
everything
a national put it up on youtube
the guns and roses accepting an award in
the [ __ ] 80s and 90s you'd sit there
and go oh my god but it's at least they
were real yeah yeah at least they were
[ __ ] real
this last night the scene i seen with
beyonce and jay-z and i've always loved
beyonce everybody knows i love beyonce i
love jay-z too but you know somebody's
gotta [ __ ] somebody after a while
there's too much money involved yeah
there's too much money there's too many
[ __ ] hoes and in the black world
they're [ __ ] slippery those dirty
hoes pay my bills all that [ __ ] you
wrote that [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know you wrote that [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know what do you think there's got to be
a hot 21 year old black chick right now
that wants that jay-z dick a little
apartment in harlem
what
close to a popeye's what
thousands of them like what's up
nothing did you find it i was it 92
maybe yeah go ahead do you want to play
it yeah look what they [ __ ] look like
look up
no that's music accepting a [ __ ] man
yeah they're they're walking up to
accept the award with the music playing
all right play play
eddie rosenblatt [ __ ] up records
sitting there laying there
i can't remember right how many how many
guys have sunglasses oh yeah this has
nothing to do at least two jackson at
least two
yeah there's one guy in the background
yeah i think it was like 91 because down
came out in 88
87 i got sentence 88 88
and [ __ ] uh you got sentence in 88
yeah and that's how i remember that that
whole
when i got sentenced the hot video was
sweet child of mine
oh that was a [ __ ] hot okay that was
the hot video already uh welcome to the
jungle was already hot it was sweet
child of mine and once i got locked up
everybody every [ __ ] white guy in
jail
i had that [ __ ] guns and roses
[ __ ] that was the [ __ ] man that album
is [ __ ] amazing appetite for this
rock yeah i used to walk around
to that i had the cassette too with a
[ __ ] walkman and [ __ ] paradise city
paralyzed silly city do you think like
beyonce knows like they must know that
they're cheating because of course
somebody [ __ ] the system look she
knows that he's a guy
who's a [ __ ] rapper who's worth 500
million dollars and he gets [ __ ]
thornham
literally from while he's asleep
until the next day
when he goes to sleep again and that he
can't you know and he's on and he's
[ __ ] you know touring all over the
world too i think it's she knows that
she knows that she can probably resist
more than he can for sure because i mean
i've been to like the comedy shows and
and girls like that girl the [ __ ]
steakhouse came up to you just and like
it's easy like when it's not that often
like you guys are only on the road for
like a little weekend
but like i can't imagine like nba
players and like oh baseball players
it's amazing girls run they know what
hotels they stay at
girls in those towns
know what hotels they're staying at what
teams what bars they go to and that's
what they [ __ ] do
that's the most [ __ ] crushing that goes
on like baseball players i say ball
basketball basketball basketball for
sure i think so yeah oh my god i think
baseball would probably be next
because this is so long of a season the
long ass season you travel and you go to
those same towns for like multiple so
you get your [ __ ] regular squeezes in
you know i mean they they're playing
that division game a few times and
baseball they're like
you know they're not even [ __ ] tired
after the game they're like i [ __ ]
stood on third for a half of the
afternoon they go back now they want to
work out basketball though those guys
are all about [ __ ] crushing it dude
and those chicks are trying half of them
are trying to get pregnant like oh
that's scary that's the whole [ __ ]
game like they'll pick up condoms out of
the way at least to get dirt on them to
get some kind of money so and you get
these [ __ ] and they're like you know
they wait they'll [ __ ] bring room
service to you these girls are like
they're sneaky man and in those in the
nba world they'll [ __ ] they'll bring
you the the room service you ordered
jesus do you ever get it because i mean
everyone knows that you guys are married
and i'm i don't know if you talk about
in your act or not but
i mean it's just
they put pictures of like
jay-z next to beyonce everyone knows
he's married to beyonce but they just
don't care it's a different thing man
they're superstars they're not they're
not it's not like they're
you know
i think it's he's a rapper like they
know that rappers are not like
you know like trying to be
upstanding and and he's a [ __ ] rapper
man he talks about beating it up and
tossing it out and it's like you know
i'll give you that sweet that nasty that
gushy stuff that like that's a [ __ ]
rap lyric of his yeah beating it up i
think it's different man when you're a
musician
and you're a world i mean he's world
famous you can you can take him anywhere
in the world it's different people are
super attracted to fame you know if he
wasn't famous it'd be way different and
there's a lot of freaks out there yeah
there's a lot of women that want to [ __ ]
there's a lot of women that want to [ __ ]
a celebrity you know a jay-z type that's
a huge gift he's uh you know he's a
gazillionaire you know i mean
they're going through whatever there's a
lot of people out there with that person
that want to ruin their life
you know
it's definitely a chance you take yeah
so it's gotta be some amount of staff
they got to do it the right way i mean
where's jay-z gonna go in new york that
somebody's not gonna know jay-z nowhere
okay so jay-z goes he probably has
guys that their job is to like
line up his [ __ ] for him you know i
mean like that's a pretty good job and
go to your mother's house like wait look
i'm going when i go to boston yeah i'm
gonna give your mom a plane ticket out
of town you're gonna get the house fixed
up yeah excellent i'm gonna have a chick
sent over and [ __ ] her at your house
i'm gonna go over there here you're
gonna go out the back door i'll give you
five thousand dollars well i give a [ __ ]
i'm worth 10 billion [ __ ] dollars
what do i give a [ __ ]
and that's the only way but all that
trickery has to get tired yeah that's
exactly that's it has to get tired i
couldn't do it i couldn't do it i
couldn't just meet somebody and hide and
take a car
all that for i come in a minute
you know all that for eating your ass
you know and then having to go home and
miss you and then
you start getting the boyfriend now
[ __ ] with my situation in my house
because now you want
that that always evolves yeah you know
doesn't it only a 21 year old would fall
for that a young man would fall for that
you know it's about man it's about
energy i wouldn't have the energy energy
to to keep up with that [ __ ] and that's
what i'm always amazed by when guys who
do that who have like the [ __ ] six
girls i'm like
like just when they tell me about it i'm
like this sounds [ __ ] exhausting yeah
you have [ __ ] five girlfriends and
then you know two others that don't know
about the and like that whole world is
like your whole like they put so much
energy into that i don't know how they
get anything else done you know what i
mean like that's their whole life yeah i
always felt i knew i didn't have a lot
of friends like that but i had like
three or four of them
and i always kind of felt bad for them
because i always knew that one they were
gonna get nailed and this comes to an
end yeah and two you're gonna pay for
your sins now you're gonna get on the
other side
yeah you know i was in a jacuzzi
uh had to be somewhere to four seasons i
was a joe or something like that
and i went to a jacuzzi and it was a guy
and then i think i told you i thought
fourth conversation he told me that his
wife
was cheating on him for 20 years
[ __ ] man
20 years they and here's the funny thing
she worked for a doctor
he's a doctor
they all went on vacations together
while they were on vacations they would
cheat
wow the guy was telling me all this and
it's like they were married
and he goes i don't know what to do i'm
old now
i don't know whether i should keep her
or
and i thought i always thought about
that conversation now
what the [ __ ] i mean i mean what the
20-something years you're cheating on
that'd be devastating to [ __ ] hear me
that'd be devastating that you just
ruined the [ __ ] life that guy's gonna
die with that on his [ __ ] mind but
his wife cheated on him for 20 something
years that guy is def she's definitely
gonna die in a house blaze or something
i mean and it's getting more accepted
like have you heard of tinder right have
you heard of joey like the dating app
where you just swipe if you think
they're hot like they have things now
and it's like people put on twitter like
oh i have a side chick and i like i i i
keep my phone out all the time like i'm
when i'm at home i have it out next to
me and if paul sees it she's gonna look
at like i would i like if i had to like
constantly be worried about someone
texting me that's that would consume you
yeah yeah of course
and it's i mean i can understand
where like if someone's out on the road
a lot they have needs but just like why
even get married then like all these
people getting split like why even get
married
listen man
we're all we're sinners right that's the
thing we're all weak there comes a point
where they're weak you know today i got
in the car and
i got home my wife was working because i
told my wife i don't want to stay in
tonight because i'm going to be in the
next three [ __ ] nights
you know next two nights i'm not good at
staying in the whole [ __ ] day i'm
gonna stay in the morning i'm writing
jokes or i'm making phone calls but
after a while i gotta get the [ __ ] out
of the house
and i said you know let's go eat
something i'm going to walk into the car
you know mercy weighs 20 something
[ __ ] pounds i'm carrying on my wrist
is hurting my knee hurts
i'm putting her in her car seat and i'm
thinking of myself what would i do to
blow this
right a line of coke
eating some 20 year old girl's [ __ ] for
five [ __ ] minutes and coming on her
neck
and then she's gonna twitch me for 18
[ __ ] days straight you know what's
gonna change this
what could change that for some guys
that's not enough
that's not enough you know i knew early
on i got cheese on when i was young i
knew that wasn't for me that feeling i
got from being cheated on i knew i never
wanted to give that to somebody so i
knew it wasn't for me then there was
another flip to that coin if i have a
friend listen you want to cheat on your
girlfriend
she deserves to be cheated on i don't
[ __ ] know
but once we're talking about wives if i
have a friend that cheats on his wife i
really can't hang out with that dude
even though i was a criminal because i
knew if he rolled on his wife he'd
definitely roll on me
if he had no dedication to whoever
sucked his dick because my dedication to
whoever said my day i understand me i
don't know about you i'm an ugly dude i
don't get my dick sucked a lot but my
point being that that was how i thought
that was how i thought from a street
perspective that this guy's cheating on
his best friend yeah
this guy's definitely gonna roll on me
i'm keeping this [ __ ] light all right
a warrior no no business because i know
it so that was the mentality i came from
i'm not gonna tell you i don't like my
dick getting sucked you know you do a
show you bump into a curtain
some chick is sucking dick through the
curtain your dick accidentally goes in
her mouth like the peanut butter
commercial your chocolate whatever my
peanut butter what's this [ __ ] happens
you know
[ __ ] happens
sometimes a woman wants to smoke a pole
she's walking around on her knees
a short guy my zip is open you know i
don't [ __ ] know but nobody's gonna
sit here and say that we haven't had
thoughts or whatever right you know
every man is weak it's it's
the thing i don't want
is making the call and hooking up with
somebody oh man and having to go home
and tell a lie then you have that on
your back
you know for months i was on that
testosterone and i heard all these
people telling me how there's hot asian
chicks
giving massages and sucking your dick
for 150
i'll borrow 150 dollars
[ __ ]
and i wouldn't do it yeah i wouldn't do
it as much as i would go by that place
by they said it by the agostino by the
haha they got a place there with asian
chicks don't stick their tongue up your
ass with
a saran wrap and
that's disgusting i heard
i heard that [ __ ] disgusting you
heard the conversation red man oh yeah
red man said he put like a baggie around
his dick yeah and another guy was coming
at the ha ha he goes there in the
afternoon right and for a buck and a
quarter the chick let him [ __ ] eat
her [ __ ] and i'm like why would you
want to eat this chick snatch
and he was telling me he was asian it
was different from whoa whoa whoa then
get yourself a clean agent
you're eating [ __ ] massage parlor
[ __ ] on lancashire do you know what's
gonna [ __ ] happen to your teeth
a dentist won't even be able to solve
that fungi on the [ __ ] thing
that [ __ ] lancashire dick
fungi on your [ __ ] teeth that you
can't wash that off with toothbrush and
colgate
cocaine ain't gonna [ __ ] bill you i
need a listerine that shit's there for
good
yeah you're right though man you can't
you can't roll with that dude you can i
know guys but you can't like hang with
that guy you know if he's like the the
[ __ ]
the guy who's always like you know lying
to his wife on top of that i know the
building's about to fall on top yeah
yeah talking about sugar night before
soon as i see sugar and i walk into a
restaurant i get to the check in fact i
might even dine and dash
because i know the building's about to
[ __ ] come down exactly exactly he's
about to come down i asked that
[ __ ] where he was on 9 11. i
guarantee that [ __ ] was standing
out there with an umbrella
you know what i'm saying that's the type
of luck that fucker's got
suge knights are [ __ ] you know he
just got the kiss of death on them you
know those guys were involved in
something when you're involved in
something all those and all that level
it's like when i got in trouble with ken
bella at the time i kidnapped kent i
wouldn't have thought i was gonna get in
trouble but not on hindsight there was
too many moving pieces do you ever think
about that if you did that crime today
like the exact same crime in 2014
wouldn't it be way more severe your
punishment
yes
like if you have
if if you did the exact same thing right
now
i thought it would be more severe
i think jail might not have been as easy
the severity well at this age no at this
age no you're gonna go into a [ __ ]
jungle into a million remember anything
over like four years they're gonna put
you into medium level
medium level you got some heavy duties
in there yeah you got some heavy duties
that are on their way back
people who were up on the high tiers who
were going down in time they had 12
years
they got six left they had no problems
they're still the same human being but
do you think the sentence would be the
same if you did this be the same yeah
today
that's what i was getting no it was a
different time yeah there was different
mitigating circumstances there was a lot
of what ifs he did this this
you know i left it open they couldn't
figure it out yeah they couldn't figure
me out that's if
if i wouldn't have had the things i had
going for me a job
no prior convictions
uh so no priors when this happened no i
had arrests
okay big difference i'm a man without
convictions
at the time i had been convicted of one
misdemeanor which was a six months
deferred percentage which meant if i
didn't get arrested in those six months
boom it fell off my record but it wasn't
a violent crime no it was a pot
crime in new york in the
january february i got convicted in
march of 83.
so after and it was new york which means
six months probation was really after 90
days he told me don't ever call him
again
huh i was so busy i went to see him
and when i went to see him i go listen
this ain't even we don't even have to
shake hands what are you talking about
i'm moving to colorado with your
permission
on the 25th and he goes
you're absolutely right he goes this is
what we're going to do just call me
everyone in the tent
he goes why are you wasting my time and
your time you're leaving anyway correct
yeah
he didn't even ask me for more transfers
he could have stopped though could he
have stopped it if you wanted to
he could have said you have to wait till
the six months i want you to take a drug
program at that time drug programs
weren't intact yet see now they have
drug programs
so now if lee gets leaves here tonight
and he gets caught with a grandma blow
okay
his attorney's gonna go first thing
tomorrow morning they're gonna grab lee
a good jew attorney
is gonna grab lee after bail and throw
him in a rehab first thing he's not even
gonna make [ __ ] uh
uh his first uh whatever [ __ ] it he was
diving that type that that's what a
smart attorney would do
that's what a smart attorney would do
grab leave first offense yeah no dui
throw him into a [ __ ] they might get
my driving under the influence throw
them into a rehab for 30 days come out
then go in front of the judge and work
the process that way there's got to be a
program where first-time offenders
if they have no police record they think
that they're never going to have a rate
of recidivism recidivism
they'll give you like four year
probation which is a debt sentence also
yeah because that means if you do
anything in four years like chris brown
you're in there again that's the problem
when you get sent don't do this real
basically don't get that [ __ ] crap so
a lot of people go [ __ ] it i'll take the
year in jail because i don't want to do
four years of probation really a lot of
people [ __ ] they don't want to live
under a magnifying glass it's life is
tough enough out there i gotta walk
around with a probation officer pissing
the bottle you got a guy when i got out
of prison i got put on community
corrections that sucked dick and after i
[ __ ] up
lee they would come to my house at 11
o'clock at night
mr diaz we know you're there
both your cars come on down please
uh come down open the door i have a
sheriff with me we're going inside to
get a urine test eleven o'clock at night
really
and this is in boulder
wow this was in boulder now when i got
arrested for the kidnapping my first
mistake was they the lawyer told him he
goes checking the rehab first thing
tomorrow morning i was like [ __ ] that i
ain't got a coke problem didn't claim
responsibility
for the claim responsibility right there
and gone to the rehab for 30 days i
would have came out into a different
situation yeah they couldn't uh
question me
they couldn't you follow me that's the
other end of the coin they can't get it
here they can't get to you yeah now it
gives us a little time to get our action
these are the moves
when you
have the money and the finances yeah a
lot of people when you're
doing drugs
you know a dollar to come out of your
pocket there's a dollar that comes out
of your nose you're not going to put
money up to get help but a smart player
goes to a rehab it's like my friend
whenever he used to get in trouble with
kids yeah he shot somebody or you he got
caught burning a house one time he fakes
a heart attack
because that gives you three days that's
an old jew trick all right make a heart
attack you fake a heart attack you have
to talk to nobody for three days you
know what i'm saying they gotta wait
till you come back they can't go into
they'll put a cop outside your door but
your attorney can still go in there and
chit-chat with you and the cops coming
we need to talk to him he's not ready
yet you got a heart attack get out of
here you're going to stress them they
don't want to stress your heart you can
sue right follow me right right yes that
movie with clintus with the enforcer no
with
walks right into a [ __ ] restaurant
and the mafia is having a dinner
and he walks right up on the ground he
goes hey
what i have in my hand is a subpoena
tomorrow morning you're gonna go to jail
for the murder of
lee siyat and for that girl you're here
sitting with your daughter i want you to
tell your family how you raped that girl
and then dragged her and put him in the
trunk of a car and killed her there's a
subpoena i'll see you in court tomorrow
let's come back and he joseph the guy
grabs his heart has a heart attack the
brother-in-law takes out the blank sheet
of [ __ ] paper you know what i'm
saying [ __ ] deadly it's one of those
enforcers
oh one of those dirty harry's it's one
of those dirty harry so
it's amazing the tricks you could
[ __ ] play yeah the other that's the
other thing the the smart move you know
when celebrities [ __ ] up like when they
make a big public [ __ ] up it's always
straight to rehab no matter what
straightforward if they say you know
they say something like the recorded
converse like mel gibson oh geez you
know then they're like he's got a
problem he's gonna go to rehab now it's
just that tactic to like buy yourself
but now people see through it like when
celebs do it like when they say
something crazy or racist then they're
like i'm going to rehab
then people now are like that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] man that's such [ __ ] we
know it's a movie we're going deep
tonight it's over speaking of doing okay
but i can't do any more than all of us
will do this no no speaking of celebs
tom just ran into mike tyson
mike did yeah you run into everybody you
ran into what's his name the rapper a
couple weeks ago too big daddy kane
where'd you run into him dude this was
crazy for kane i talk about him in my
special
and uh i have a bit where i talk about
seeing him and yelling out to him
and they put it on youtube so i sent i
tweeted him like hey man did you see
this
and he wrote back like i did like it's
hilarious somebody told me about it so i
thought it was cool and that that was it
you know he tweeted me back
and then like two days later i'm home
and i get a voicemail like i walk
to the car and i say i got a voicemail
and i check it and
it's big daddy kane and he's like what's
up tom
uh i'm chilling over at uh your boy
russell's house russell peters
so
then russell texted me he's like kane's
over here right now
come over to my house and i was like get
the [ __ ] out
so i drove over there
couldn't he could not be a cooler dude
he told me that his engineer
uh you know that he like in the studio
saw the bit and told him about it and
that a bunch of people have played but
he couldn't have been and now i tweet
with him like all the time
he's just uh he's a cool dude man what
about tyson where'd you bump into that
savage on a flight on a flight from la
to pittsburgh and man people go nuts
when they see tyson people go nuts and
he's great he's [ __ ] and he's gracious
he shook everybody everybody's happy
everybody he's very [ __ ] uh you know
what what you see is that
the amount of people you know like every
like people that are joey diaz fans yeah
there's there's a wide variety or let's
you know let's take another like uh
another actor or artist or athlete
there's like but there's that range of
person that's like your fan
with tyson
old white ladies
uh [ __ ] teenage black
uh
45 year old white guy in other words
everybody
wants to say something to him it's not
just who like you know a certain
demographic it's the whole [ __ ] world
boarding the plane
stopped and said so they they held up
the [ __ ] line
to board where the flight attendant was
like you have to keep
you have to keep moving and they're like
i want to talk to mike like
i can't believe they didn't board him
last
well you know what what are you gonna do
like they can't really do anything so
they yeah we're russian you know how
funny is that he got convicted of rape
and went to prison
there's something about people and they
get convicted or rape they have a power
over people and they walk over a room
[ __ ] like that dude
i gotta shake his [ __ ] hand
i gotta get his [ __ ] autograph i
doubt they brought that up when they
were saying hi they do this damn
[ __ ] these old white guys were
kissing his ass yeah it's amazing he's
crazy i've seen him at ufc i've seen
when that whole thing came when he first
went to ufc
how people going nuts people and i love
him he's an interesting guy man
he's a very interesting guy and it's
amazing that he's prevailed it is
amazing that he's had 22 lives he's had
tremendous pain
you know he lost a kid at his house i
mean
guys you have no idea he lost his father
his family his train he was sexually
abused that guy's always got a [ __ ]
smile on his face and yeah they got him
on medication or whatever you know when
he's around too you don't know like
sometimes you look at him going man
this guy might snap if he snaps got that
look in his head he's got that look in
his eye you know and that's uh and by
the way he could still
[ __ ] wreck somebody really he's in
his family yeah no he's he's not in good
shape for him like he'd consider himself
out of shape right now but he still has
the power dude you see it i mean you can
see first of all like when he moves it
just moves his arm like he has an
enormous enormous but you know he's got
the walk like the walk comes from it's
like a power way of walking like he
throws his hips the same way you get
power and a punch you know it's from
it's all from like the lower body and
he's just he he literally he walks it
looks like a [ __ ] pit bull you know
it's like it's cr you know that he could
absolutely if you want to use his two
shots against you because you might put
your hand up and catch the one and he'll
just hit you in the chest and the air is
going to go out of your chest yeah and
he's going to come up with that [ __ ]
left hook
and that's it for you and you know
that's the people that were fighters
that got used to it yeah guys like me
and you we just go down oh yeah god go
down
internally
i was talking not i talked to him about
fighting for a while he came to my show
that's the other thing i met him on a
plane then he came to the show it's a
[ __ ] mess
and he hung out in the green room and
[ __ ] we just talked about fighting
but i was talking to somebody about you
know he was trained by customato and
then the other guy that was like in the
ring with him all the time as teddy
atlas who calls fights now on like espn
he's great he's fantastic and they were
saying that somebody asked him i guess
on one of these shows like so was tyson
like like this uh
uh just natural like savant fighter like
a prodigy like just he got in the ring
and just knew how to fight and they said
that uh you know he was he was powerful
as [ __ ]
that is natural but he was getting hit a
lot
he was getting hit all the time
and then they told they said that when
we taught him how to slip punches
and then when he learned that nobody
wanted to fight him anymore like nobody
wanted to spar with him anymore once he
knew how to slip punch because he was
getting
hit a lot yeah but once he knew how to
slip punches they were like we had to
like [ __ ]
bust people in to fight him because
everybody in around there was like oh no
i'm good man like that was do they have
these on tape somewhere because like
i've never seen a mike ty i know all of
them are using clips like an entire mike
tyson fight do they have like just reels
oh yeah i would love to see that oh yeah
man you can dude youtube has youtube
okay hour fights hours youtube has
a guy that probably put together just
his knockouts to get you started oh yeah
yeah just his knockouts to get you
started and that's you know i got
addicted to roberto durant on youtube
okay a year do you want to hear this go
ahead okay so
well first of all you know i meet him on
the plane and he couldn't be nicer
durian no no no tyson tyson and we
anyways i talked to him for a while on
the plane and i give him my number and
he ends up texting me and then calling
me and then coming to the show in
pittsburgh which is [ __ ] bananas
and then we're in the green room and
we're talking about
you know i'm just i can't believe him
[ __ ] he came to my show i'm just
talking i'm just like asking him
questions and then we talk about um
workouts and i was like you know how his
workouts if you want to see something
insane it's like him work just a a gym
workout when he's like
18 19 20 21 they're the most they're
bananas okay like
jump rope with the bag and then speed
back and then the sit-ups like this guy
worked out it's just like
you can't even wrap your head around it
i told him i was watching uh also
because different you know all those
boxers are just tremendous [ __ ]
they're amazing athletes roy jones jr do
it and uh and then tyson goes uh
nah man my guy is roberto duran yeah and
i go what and he goes yeah that's my guy
that's your school of thought bernie
duran was a school of thought
and it's you could see the people who
you could see
tennyson people
you could see dice people you could see
that i'm from the dice school of thought
i'm also from the rodney dangerfield
school of thought even though i love
bill hicks or whatever
he's from the
duran school of thought which is to go
in there and [ __ ] kill you
it's a different savage and i know that
the workouts like i read the durand book
and
you know i know a lot of people knew
duran and it was [ __ ] crazy and yeah
he's got the reputation for no moss but
there's more behind that story yeah what
do you think happened to boxing because
like these fighters took over the
country like ali thais and all these
people and now it's just nowhere it's
just almost gone
you know it's all peaks and valleys you
know and uh what was in the comedy with
the comedy boom was the mid 80s yeah
through the 80s and they started the
death started in like early like 91 92
as well and you know everything there's
peaks and valleys then it came back in
2000
for 10 years it was dead boxing it seems
like it's been that a little longer it
has been yeah then 10 years you know and
you know what you need man you need an
awesome like if floyd
mayweather he was by the way huge draw
still sells huge tickets yeah but if he
was a heavyweight
we are just obsessed
with bigger and bigger bigger is always
what if he was as good as he is a
heavyweight
boxing would be even
like way more popular yeah i mean i love
a heavyweight i guess that's kind of the
same in ufc everyone everyone likes the
john dodson and like the small guys but
everyone comes out for the like light
heavyweight and up or middleweight
enough i guess they want to see it man
they want to see it do you see the ads
that are out for like it's like knockout
boxing it's like a tiny ring it's just a
circle and they just there's no space so
like all they can do is just throw
handmakers at each other it's on it's
been on tv for pay-per-view it's crazy
really it's just it's a small ring
there's no cage there's no ropes so it's
just the other thing
i'm sorry to cut you off but about a guy
like tyson too
is that he knew
how popular he was
and he knew that people wanted to see a
show he was aware of that
and a lot of guys who fight these days
you'll see like a lot of things about
boxers now is like
i mean but you know
a good boxer does
you know learn learn your style learn
what you're doing and adapt and try to
try to attack your weaknesses but tyson
on top of having that skill was still
aware that like
not only is this arena full but millions
and millions of people and i'm gonna put
like i'm gonna go for it because i know
people wanna see the knockout so even if
he doesn't get it
he would go for the knockout because he
knows that part of it is being a showman
that's part of being a world-class prize
fighter is it's a show you know you want
to see you don't want to watch a guy
dance for [ __ ] 10 rounds do you no i
don't see a guy just [ __ ] slip and
then if i can run around the ring i want
to see him go for the night that's when
everyone stands up i don't know
everything about boxing but that's one
of the criticisms i heard of mayweather
jr is that his past few fights he wins
but it's just he wins because he's a
smarter boxer and it's not
he's he's
the most skilled in that class i think
by far i think he's the most so he has
the skills to do
whatever he wants i think the older he
gets
the more he definitely wants to keep
that zero in the loss column
and even though he can he could go in
there and just trade punches and
probably end up doing some severe damage
maybe even
knock people out or down at least i
think as as he knows the career is
winding down
the zero in the last column becomes more
precious and you go like dude i want to
go down as no losses i think that's in
his head you know it's funny how he he's
fighting canelo next
again yeah yeah yes yes you're right yes
i did it and it's no
canelo
no no just fought right right so i'm
sorry he's fighting the guy he's
rematching the guy right argentinian
uh uh marquez no no uh fighting lisa man
i'm gonna look forward though yeah he's
rematching that dude that took him to 14
rounds or 15 rounds that was a great
fight the argentinian yeah yeah yeah and
then but it's funny how when i was
growing up
my donna madonna yeah madonna it was
like you know you had duran and sugar
ray leonard and thomas hearns and
you know marvin hagler and it was just
this whole alexis arguelle you had these
personalities and yes muhammad ali was
still there you know
but you had it seems like it's not like
that in boxing you have three or four
guys that you're basically interested in
that you know of and true and you do it
that's how i feel that's i'm not gonna
that's how i am with boxing i know the
the kiss goes
let's go guys
brothers i know
uh
pacquiao it sounds crazy but like well
part of it is that
we're speaking as americans in america
but we need americans
in the whatever is the biggest thing in
the division for whatever sport to be
the best for america to be into it
if team usa
got to the final like juan for sure but
if they even got to the finals of the
world cup you would see
a crazy boost there's a boost that
happened more people than ever in this
country watch that like the world cup
became more interesting to them and
soccer and you saw the interest go up i
saw more people than ever talking about
it and watching those if that team
were to to go on further you would see
something crazy happen and the same
thing happens with that the klitschkos
are bad
for american fans of boxing because they
don't ultimately don't give a [ __ ] we
know who they are
but no one cares yeah you know what i
mean like we need americans to [ __ ]
dominate for us to be really excited
about it that's true
that's true and i've noticed it
even at ufc matches like i've always
said the the christmas card the new
year's card after christmas day
that card has to be a little bit more
american than most of the cars
throughout the year a lot of people go
to vegas they they buy tickets just to
go see the ufc and they know you know
you want to chuck the dells on that card
you want
the uh you know captain america on that
card you want you want the rich
franklins on that card for which show
specific for which one christmas shirt
is one after december 25th this year
it's january 2nd
but they usually have a december 29th
show december 28th
if you look at those throughout the year
for those to really be good you have to
uh stop touching the mic somebody keep
touching the mic
move your cell phones away from the
[ __ ] mics and [ __ ]
uh
and i've noticed it that on those cars
throughout the year they could have
brazilians headline
that card but for that december 29th
they always like like ronda rousey and
gina carano would do great on that card
this year now it's cornmeal against jon
jones you know that's a well-known you
follow me but they'll have
gina carano and uh whatever they want
that on that so it's just amazing the
difference and when you go to the ufc
you hear people chanting and i forget
sometimes you ask say i'm like why the
[ __ ] yeah oh he's fighting a brazilian
guy he's fighting a chinese guy but
you'll see it too if you do the road one
like i've gone to one in australia
and i've gone to one in canada
and whenever they obviously bring out
the the fighter from that country the
place goes nuts which until it makes
total total sense i don't mind if they
go nuts it's when it's not going you as
oh yeah well that's different now this
poor little [ __ ] chinese guy in the
ufc he's feeling bad he's in the ring by
himself
you feel bad about it i really do it
embarrasses me like you're making he's
our guest
and you're making them [ __ ] feel
better but let me see you fly 12 hours
from your country without an octopus
next to you whatever the [ __ ] they eat
and then you go to vegas and you got to
[ __ ] lose 10 pounds and you got to
walk and you got to fight some guy and
while you're fighting people yelling usa
and you're from little [ __ ] hong kong
you know you're five foot six
you know what i'm saying you were
trained to you're acting you were
you were trained to be a butler and here
you are people yelling [ __ ] usa usa
so it bothers the [ __ ] out of me when i
go to those things i'm like really i
always get uncomfortable just at that
chant honestly anywhere like that for
some reason you know maybe it's like
it's like some weird like thing about if
you're when you're from like
the big like the the most powerful
country in the world to hear people
chant it at like bar i i get
uncomfortable with it you know i mean
like i just do even obviously
in this country when people are like i
feel like it's almost obnoxious like to
be it makes me feel bad yeah i don't
know why
i just feel bad wait what if he's a
little kid he's in there boxing he's a
little [ __ ] like lee like
your buddy bisping kicked ass this past
weekend i think we get to see the whole
thing but just i saw the end oh my god
you know we were talking about that with
rich franklin last week come at least 42
years old
your body is one thing yeah you know uh
you never really want to accept your age
you always accept well i'm in great
shape for 51 great
great that doesn't mean i'm going to go
fight somebody yeah you know when you're
i think after a certain age i gotta tell
you something look at him by looking at
his face
my thing comes right in his vision his
his hand to
coordination was completely [ __ ] off
or bismay takes took speed tablets and
you can't see his [ __ ] hands
look at his face nobody could catch you
that many times
unless you and bro i'm telling you your
reactions go after a certain age
you think your hands here but it's
really [ __ ] down here
you know he's 40 [ __ ] two years old
how many trt shots you think unless you
stick them right in your [ __ ]
eyeballs you can see through walls and
ain't gonna [ __ ] help you you know
what i'm saying so
do you feel your hand eye coordination
changed
no but i know it did i know i still
can't steal a basketball from you you
know when i was [ __ ] 16 i could like
to lift the ball for me if you were
dribbling so just left your hand i'm on
you i got your shorts you're dead i
can't do that now
i can't do that i was telling uh the jiu
jitsu guy yesterday
and i he goes that's a great pass i do
this uh
this tackle pass
and he goes you have to you really
getting good at it that's all i got
oh yeah i'm 51. i can't move my foot to
drop the knee in your belly i can't do
that i tried it you flipped me right
over
all i got is the tackle pass that means
i put your [ __ ] ankles together and i
put this shoulder on your knees and i
work you up like a spider and then i try
to choke you go for your [ __ ] arm
before i lay on you for 15 minutes and
get my oxygen back
you know i'm not gonna lie to nobody
here but that's what works for me at
this age sure i'm 300 pounds if i tackle
bastion pin your knees down and put my
shoulder into you yeah i got you
you're trying to fight me sideways it
ain't gonna work i got your legs it's
over i took your legs from me now i lay
on top
until you huff and puff when i start
going for your [ __ ] arm whoever huffs
and puffs first the most there was a
policeman under my head
i kept looking at i was laying on top of
the guy but i was sideways and the sweat
was hit and i looked down and it was
[ __ ] three inches of moisture
jiu-jitsu you sweat so [ __ ] much plus
it was 90 [ __ ] degrees
have you done it lee no i haven't i just
started working out like two months ago
he's on the 11th so he's a purple belt
in the elliptical again so you're doing
elliptical that's what i've been doing
for now but then uh i'm ready for
another album
but uh there was a there was like a
groupon deal yeah for like 25 classes
for no 15 classes for 25 bucks right
down the street so and joey's been
telling me to do new stuff because it's
going to get boring and it is a little
bit i mean cardio has been working for
me so far but i figure in 15 kettlebell
classes i can like
learn the basic technique and then do it
on my own is that what you're doing yeah
i mean i i haven't taken a class yet but
uh that's what you're going to do yeah
i'm going to try to just i've never i i
i was on teams a little bit in high
school but i was never good it was just
i was just doing it so you were you all
exercised
played one i played freshman year of
football and then i i wrestled yeah [ __ ]
yeah but it was playing football
[ __ ]
nothing i i never i didn't play when i
was a little kid and i the first time i
ever went was freshman year and i was
terrible i think i i played like two
plays the entire year but it was just i
don't know it was they put you on the
line of course i mean i wasn't i was it
wasn't this big and i can't run but it
was uh
and i was always terrible at sports
where was this what city uh right
outside about like 45 minutes outside of
boston
uh and the school was terrible at
football
but um did you get [ __ ] wrecked do
you remember no i i i mean a a couple
times during
uh practice and then
okay
so
one time during football practice i
almost thought i was going to puke and i
pretended i did so i could get out of
the rest of practice because i just i it
wasn't for me but when i first started
working out a couple months ago
the first time i lifted it a little bit
past like the first day i did it i slept
for 15 hours
like the first time i went over like i
tried pushing myself i had to sit in the
gym locker room for like 10 minutes
because i was sure i was gonna puke
really yeah oh yeah i was in what how
old this is two weeks ago
this is two weeks ago yeah like a month
and a half ago yeah
but uh no it's crazy how much i can do
now and it's it's a lot of fun but it's
just it's awesome man i was never good
at it and i know my kids are gonna be
terrible at it but i i think it's
important to do sports and i think
even if you're going to be bad at it
yeah of course because like i that's i
was always a bigger kid but like i
didn't know that because you never gave
it a chance no i was just talking i was
battling everything
but you had to give it a chance i was
horrible at [ __ ] basketball my sixth
grade yet i'm a short jew what do you
want me to play we don't do anything
horrible that's you gotta be good at
something no you gotta be good at
lifting weights uh a strength team we
gotta put you you know what i was like
the one thing i was i was happy with is
i never really got pinned in wrestling i
was always able to kind of like sneak
out i would i would lose a lot but i
would sneak out the whole time but do
you guys have like plays you remember i
remember i was in like second grade and
the highlight of my baseball career was
one i hit a triple one game and then
once at second base the guy hit it right
into my glove i didn't even have to move
my hand
i don't know i have i have like vivid
because i have so little sports oh
that's highlights for sure i remember i
remember that place for the same reason
yeah i remember plays
because our bank of them is a small tiny
well i mean i have a like uh
basically a bank from like fourth grade
through high school but then if you talk
to somebody that played
college or professional obviously like
their bank of memories you know but like
i i vividly remember
like certain i remember getting my
actually a guy
like the first like not just uh
big strong guy but savvy you know i mean
by savvy like this dude actually
figured out most on the high school
level you're not talking about like it's
just like your pure ability yeah like
are you a really good athlete are you a
mediocre athlete
and then you're just using your outlet
but some guys are like
like tacticians and it's really rare at
that age i remember this guy just being
able to like
read what i did and then i remember one
of his moves like was just to give you a
head slap over your ear hole and he was
a football yeah man those ring
differently those [ __ ] hurt
so much more than like
somebody throwing a
shoulder or arm into your chest like he
gave me the head slap on the side and i
was like what the [ __ ] and he knew what
he was doing you know and like he knew
like he led me into it even like he like
walked me into it and then came around
with his big long [ __ ] arm he was
probably six six you know like six five
six six and a big kid for a [ __ ] high
school kid like 270 like he was a big
guy
and those guys like you don't you don't
see that every like in not every high
school team has that [ __ ] guy you
know where he's not just like a big
strong kid but he knows like the insides
of like how to figure out what you're
doing
it's really rare yeah
i was terrible really i was telling you
you practiced basketball i was terrible
in baseball listen
wait three things to be bad in baseball
when you're cuban
okay and i joined the north bergen
leagues i joined the stickleball leagues
in new york i was good in new york the
prom i always had growing up and he
ended up we never talked so it's great i
had a big problem like i was great in
practice
yeah but i was horrible in games
so with baseball did you get nervous i
don't know what it was with baseball
i i remember my highlight of baseball
was winning the ball
at uh red berries baseball camp in miami
won something i won the
uh
in leaguer of the week
like i was the best uh
camper yeah not the camper of not the
best on the team but for the week i was
the best infielder okay i was the first
baseman i
got two balls and i threw a guy at
second and i got three hits but then
when i go to northbrook and i'd strike
out and balls would go between my legs
and then i tried uh basketball
and i was [ __ ] horrible at that and
then i got into football and football i
showed a little promise when it was uh
13 to 15
because i couldn't play in high school
because i was always 143. you couldn't
weigh more than 135.
what so yeah in high school you had one
not high school middle school grammar
school yeah the eagles and the red
raiders so you had to be 125 and 135
for the raiders i was always tall and
lanky so i couldn't [ __ ] and my bones
were heavy so i didn't you know joey
diaz tall and lanky
did you see the
okay with my needle shoulders i used to
have my freshman year
and then again freshman year went on i
sucked in football but
i tell you why i started to break out
karate i would go to karate and i went
to karate so much during the week that
obviously you get good
so go to those little fifth grade sixth
grade tournaments point sparring and i
would do good
yeah not as good as i do in the [ __ ]
class though and the class i had i
always had great endurance and i always
had flexibility so i was into these nice
little kung fu kicks and [ __ ] but in
tournaments guys were kicking my legs
and [ __ ] like that and it was a
different game yeah i would have to
fight guys that weren't good at kicking
legs i would have to pick my bracket and
you know i knew how to convince them
yeah you know
so
that's what then basketball was where
hard work came in
i knew i was bad and i was so bad that i
wrote to every college coach that i
admired
i got a book and i wrote to duke to bill
foster i wrote to dean smith
you wrote letters letters the guy from
syracuse marty head he's been there for
thirty thousand yeah not mario i forget
what his name is jim calhoun
no that's uconn beijing john behind i
wrote him a letter in 77 78 and they all
sent me packages
on how to improve they did yeah that's
something about there's some quality
yeah
a real coach these coaches all had
packages at that time because they're
recruits then i would send i went to
five star i went first i went to willis
reed basketball camp then i went to
booze basketball camp and then i went to
another bat and i was really good
by the time i got to the eighth grade
people were like what the [ __ ] happened
it was all summer long
it was riding a bicycle with a
basketball in the middle up and down
hills
you know go home he didn't sit against
the wall and he didn't work on my
defense go back to the court and you
know i read that jerry west took 300
jump shots a day done
300 junk shots is how i started my
morning
i wouldn't even go play until i hit 300
jump shots and then i got on the bicycle
and go
to union city west new york and you
always was in front and it's just like
common yeah
that was the first blueprint of my
comedy career
you know you want to get good you got to
go to west new york you got to go in the
morning you got to wait to get picked
and once they pick you you better hoop
because if you don't hoop they're never
gonna pick you again for another year oh
we had that white [ __ ] he can't
who i just take a bus to hoboken i used
to [ __ ] go everywhere and then we
started going into the city
[ __ ] your freshman year three white boys
let's go into the boogie down we go up
there get a nickel bag smoke a [ __ ]
number and play with the black dudes but
you had to cover your ass for them to
have your back if you didn't do well or
you started trouble you couldn't come
back so
that's how i did it so you were playing
ball in the city doing this [ __ ] like
[ __ ] yeah all the way then once i went
to freshman year the dream got [ __ ] up
i smoked some reefer i did a little
crystal thc
and i went to see the new barbarians
with mick jagger uh with ron wood and
the new barbarians and that was it that
was it that's [ __ ] badass joey
running the courts and [ __ ]
the bronx do you guys remember the worst
that you ever did would you guys play
for money
once i didn't play high school ball
anymore i would play for money in the
afternoons behind hashways
ten dollars twenty dollars and i would
oh and then i would always be like i'm
hurt
i'm not doing this no more so guys are
always like the guys in the bar would
have a couple drinks and we'd get them
for a grandma blow and [ __ ]
and one day was a situation a guy went
through his car and got a chain jesus
said he said we what what do you call
that when you set people up oh yeah yeah
a ringer or something we were ringers we
would set [ __ ] up but i
remember one time
being out of high school and and being a
drug dealer and a criminal and going to
a party in sea caucus
and me and some guys were at a party
hanging out and these guys come up
through how do you want to play yeah 50
a game i'm like and they're looking at
me like let's turn these [ __ ]
up
it was a seven point game they scored
seven unanswered points and took our
money we just got in the car and went
home
we couldn't even believe it these guys
were sensational where was it irish guys
and secrets these white dudes just took
it
what the [ __ ] one nothing
two nothing and here's the crazy thing
guys we were 18 19. yeah these guys were
men
these guys like 28 just took our [ __ ]
50 bucks
we went home depressed as [ __ ] crazier
when like i used to play a lot of
basketball like basically
up until high school and then i started
again in college so like i didn't play
that much in high school after freshman
year
and what's even crazier i feel like is
like when i was like 22
and i probably got in the best shape i'd
ever been in playing basketball all the
time
and i played a game against two
it was me and one and a guy who was all
who's like 30 something against two
sophomores in high school two
15 year old kids and they
were unfucking believed
like i was like oh [ __ ] like we are
[ __ ] at we're like old guys and i was
22 at the time and in good i mean i was
like 190 i was running working at
playing ball all the time pickup games
all the time and those two kids
were
the kid that i covered was at least four
inches shorter than me and was jumping
like a full foot higher than me
like it was crazy to see somebody
kick your ass like that who's 15 years
old
you know it's amazing how i blame a lot
of things
basketball broke my heart when i didn't
really attain the goals i wanted to in
basketball it really [ __ ] with me for
a long time really
and i think that when i started comedy i
used the same work ethic and i knew what
i had to do not to fail like i did with
basketball
like i took basketball too seriously and
when i heard the first hurdle i said
that's it i can't take the heartbreak
really you know i let it go and listen
what had been in the nba no
well i had stopped doing drugs no
but i would have had something
i would have played those four years i
would have had something
my life i don't know i don't know i just
uh a friend of mine called me last week
and said that uh
he hadn't felt this bad in 30 years he
took his kid to college
and this guy's successful you know he's
a friend of mine he's got three kids
he said it didn't bother him
when he took his older daughter as much
as this daughter
because he realized what he didn't do
with his life
and i totally understood
a couple weeks ago i went to the college
somewhere and i'm like yeah i wish i had
the chance to come back to [ __ ] here
as much as i know now like i always sell
lee when you go to interviews for
editing they don't talk to you about
emerson college no
nobody asks you about your college
education to me because i didn't really
get it the proper way i always felt
[ __ ] guilty yeah like if i knew now
like i i was telling my wife that i was
telling my wife about this how uh
i got this call and we were talking and
she goes you know i feel the same way
when i was talking to my niece about her
classes
like you i would have done a different i
took a dog when i went to college they
would give it away to minorities and
boulder i was getting money from that
[ __ ]
student union on a [ __ ] on a whim
just on a phone call you got my credit
right just give me another 25 50. i
decided to take a chemistry class and
[ __ ] it was amazing and i feel bad that
i didn't take advantage of all that i
was a cop student which meant that if i
kept a 2.0 grade average
they would allow me to [ __ ] stay in
school
and i kept that but they had free
tutoring
they had all these services that you had
to pay for the student services i got
for free i didn't take advantage of that
[ __ ] i didn't belong to a fraternity
which i knew i wouldn't but who knew
maybe there's a criminal fraternity yeah
maybe there's a fraternity of [ __ ]
gangsters or [ __ ] ex-felons or
potential felons i don't [ __ ] know
but i missed that whole experience you
had it bert had it you had it
and uh not to have it you feel or i had
it to a degree
i had i'll tell you when i first walked
on the university of colorado
i forgot about everything bad i had ever
done in my life like it had observed me
just by getting there just by taking the
two [ __ ] classes the first time it
changed my life it gave me more esteem
at that time it helped big time yeah
because
i quit high school
my my freshman year my my freshman year
my senior year in september because i
had to get a job but i went back in
december and i took all my courses and
in june they came to me they go you know
you're three credits short
you can't graduate we gotta go to summer
school uh i gotta tell you something
i'm not going to summer school and you
[ __ ] are a bunch of [ __ ]
because i play track
i play basketball i play freshman
football they're gonna give me three
credits for each one
you know they've done it before they
were like nah we don't think so okay you
[ __ ] so i didn't really get my
diploma
when i got arrested
no when i when i went to i went to
colorado mountain college i had i had
gotten too many credits so they told me
how to
take my credits to a different school so
i went to the university of boulder
continuing ed once i took like another
30 credits there they were like you have
too many credits have been continuing in
you got to register into the [ __ ]
college
and i'm like i'm never going to get into
the [ __ ] college they go well you
have no choice you can't keep coming
back here we're going to stop giving you
money that was the magic word money is
my motivator [ __ ] what do i need
to do where you need to come with your
high school transcripts so i went and
got a high school diploma
took my saps i did all that [ __ ] at 23
or something i did all that [ __ ]
you're following me yeah that's crazy
that's [ __ ] crazy and i got in and i
bro when they gave me my first check
the first time i looked at my schedule
i had tears in my eyes like that was one
of the happiest days of my life why
because
i had made my mother proud you know this
is just the university of colorado this
ain't no [ __ ] uh community college of
[ __ ] denver it was a big deal for you
this was a big deal for me i didn't want
to go there me i'd rather be a duke jack
you know me i'd rather be a kentucky
[ __ ]
blue devil or [ __ ] boston college but
boulder i got in they accepted me
and i walked around i took classes and
then i got in trouble
once i got the felony i went back and
said none i should have just dropped out
but see i opened my mouth
and i went to the guy i had my family go
to the guy who got me in there and tell
him the truth
and he was goody two shoes he goes well
i don't know if we could have him back
on the campus with the felonies
especially for kidnapping and drugs i
know the drugs are definitely out
kidnapping they might let them out we
got football players that have done
worse
you know
that's what happened wow but i i regret
not like having and i've told you we've
had this conversation that
i don't it breaks my heart that when you
go for an interview now and even you
you went to college yeah i got a great
degree and you're [ __ ] comedian you
know but
like sometimes a guy like me would go
looking [ __ ] a girl with that [ __ ]
momo five years to become a comedian but
his [ __ ] father's happy paid for that
[ __ ] but it was an experience for you
there was an experience where did you go
to school i went to a tiny school called
lenoir-rhyne college in hickory north
carolina damn yeah as small as [ __ ] you
know why i went there
it's the only school that let me in i
had such a bad high school transcript
like
bad gpa i had decent s.a.t but bad gpa
i couldn't get in anywhere they let me
in so i just that was the only place i
applied got in
but it was an experience because i have
still have friends today from then which
i i [ __ ] think is great and um
you know i used to complain a little bit
about it
about like how
it was such a small school because my in
my mind
going to college was like movies like
animal house yeah yeah and i was like
my expectations were like
um you know a stadium for the football
team
uh an undergrad of like just 10 at least
10 000 if not 30 000 undergrad
and i thought it would just be like what
you see college would be like it was
that
like shrunk down
to like you know less than two thousand
undergrad you know i mean so like yeah
it's just a different experience and it
wasn't the experience that i was
expecting yeah i treated college like a
bit it was basically like a business
sort of you know emerson college in
boston boston it's big for film and
writing and it really helped me when i
got out here but i didn't have any
friends i don't have any friends from
college because i went i i should have
went to drexel in philly it didn't have
as great of a program
but for what what did you go for film
film video stuff like that you went for
four years yeah well three i i did it in
three because i hated it didn't a lot
didn't have some comics on emerson
probably oh leno um
and uh henry winkler and uh but yeah i
mean it was great for that but like i
thought i was i went to visit my friend
at uh dickinson and that's not even that
big but
uh
no no
right by philly um
it has like the big brick buildings and
the rolling hills and football games
and this one was like
all the hipster kids you see and they're
all talking about the french movie they
saw and i just i hated it but yeah i
mean i'm glad i did it because now
like my dad was in radio for all those
years and and worked in restaurants but
he he dropped out of college after like
two weeks because he had a job and it
just didn't make sense but you can't get
any job now like anything you know what
at all you know the other thing that i i
don't always realize that college serves
for though is like you go there
and it helps you realize in a safer
setting
[ __ ] that you don't want to do as an
adult and i think i kind of figured out
by going to all these structured things
that i didn't want to work in structure
like work with like
get up and go to work i guarantee you if
they go to every
[ __ ] senior before they graduate
and go do you want to really go into the
field you study in college and get this
degree uh i'd really be surprised what
the percentages are it's gotta be the
kids are [ __ ] up yeah kids that didn't
know what they were getting because i
don't think the kids prepared to make it
the right decision at 18 18 yeah and
i'll tell you what really [ __ ] helped
me
more than college i tell you what
really [ __ ] help me and every day i
think about i'm like wow
with car sales
yeah that helps you figure it out
when i sold cars in college it really
sped up everything i had everything i
thought
came in you know you go to jiu jitsu
they teach you a technique
but when you're going to do it to leave
you they don't tell you that reason hide
that arm oh he's not just going to leave
the arm it's like anything else when you
go to karate class he's going to throw a
punch the punch is going to land here
you're going to hook the arm and you're
going to hit him in the rear base like
no it's not going to happen that way
he's going to wear his shirt and your
hands going to get caught
so it was really weird that you heard
all these things about business you
spoke to people
and once you discovered belly-to-belly
sales it was dude i mean that stayed
with me forever i learned more from
those criminals
on how to treat people and how to carry
myself in business
little things when you buy a t-shirt
from me i write you a letter
i got that from selling cards
when you came to see me the first thing
when you got home the next day you got a
letter from me
because i knew the other guy wasn't
sending you all that he was gonna call
you and tell you there was a sale
that's great i'm gonna send you a letter
and thank you
you know and it just taught me little
things follow-up calls
lee and i were talking about a sponsor
earlier and we were talking about our
plan of attack that plan i didn't get
that from a book i didn't study
marketing in college i got that from
selling cars
the strategy there's a strategy to
things you know and it was just really
and i worked in a place in boulder which
was really decent you know they were on
yelp today they'd have like a high
[ __ ] yelp
because that was their thing
they knew to get the good cars you had
to have a good csi a customer service
index
at that time so they specialized in that
they weren't thieves they wouldn't throw
your keys on the thing if you told them
you were unhappy they they give you the
keys right back you do that douglas
toyota in nevada to [ __ ] stab you
you'll have to talk to 18 people before
you get your car back from a trade what
car the volkswagen i just gave it for
the appraisal we don't know no
volkswagen they make you buy the car
because they hide [ __ ] from you this
place was legit
and i learned so much from those white
dudes they were [ __ ] uh mormons
really the one i need to call me the
renegade
he loved me so call me the running game
because he goes you always go off
against the people i don't like i love
it i only have to do my job
really if they're a scumbag you sniff
them out i used to lie i loved this
subaru place that was the first car i
sold you really you could sniff out the
scumbags quick i bet you yeah until
today i still drive a subaru because of
that job i am sold on subaru because of
that job because everybody how many cars
i sold and how many people's faces would
come back and go hey man
a week after you saw me calling that
blizzard we got i was in the car with my
daughter and we spit off the road if i
would have my old car i would have been
dead right now
that subaru you sold me [ __ ] had the
extra so i felt good about what i sold
i really did feel good i remember when i
got arrested i was at a chrysler store
and i went back that chrysler store was
eight drug dealers
that would lie to you about [ __ ]
everything i couldn't [ __ ] believe it
they would lie to old people used to
drive me [ __ ] crazy
like i had even even when i was a crazy
criminal i didn't see you know it was a
dodge store poll people buy [ __ ]
dodges and chrysler barons and [ __ ] like
that christ's little band with a piece
of [ __ ] that [ __ ] car was we had it
when i was growing up if you slammed the
car though everything would break the
[ __ ]
the tire on the other side would go flat
you're like what the [ __ ] i slammed this
door i didn't like that i didn't like
lying to customers i didn't like hiding
from customers i wanted to sell you
something for you to come back the next
thing and say joel you're [ __ ] up
maybe like [ __ ] happens every day
let's go fix it
instead of hiding from you you know
the subaru place they were they all wore
sandals they ate granola
they were buddhists
but those guys were pulling down i was
pulling down in college i was pulling
down anywhere from seven grand
i think about that a week or a month a
month seven grand in high school
my my
i was 24 years old
and i was making seven to 10 grand a
month off the bat
like the first day i [ __ ] started
that first month was like i got a check
for 4900 bucks i was like done
plus i walked with like a thousand and
get you know every time you sell a car
so they took that out of the check and i
flipped out but then i figured out how
taxes were paid i always wondered so
like let's say you bought a car for 10
grand how much does a salesman get okay
in these days this day you got
i forget what it was but in those days
if you sold the subaru mini deal was 100
but after the person left you got a kid
a kit and you called the subaru dealer
and they'd send you a check from 250 to
700
you get that every thursday
so i wouldn't give a [ __ ] if you came to
me and said joey i got a car for 16.60 i
could do that i knew i was gonna make a
hundred and two fifty on the back end so
that's 350 a car you do the paperwork in
15 [ __ ] minutes
you're following me there's those type
of there's so many type of deals and
there's okay i have a used car we have
six thousand in it
uh you come in and buy the car for ten
that means we made four thousand dollar
profit i get thirty percent of that so
what's ten percent four so i get twelve
hundred dollars to sell that [ __ ] car
i sell ten or twelve of those [ __ ] okay
then
if you sell seven cars you get a 500
bonus
if they if i would go into a car lot and
you'd say to me oh joey by the way the
jeep
the 89 jeep with ten thousand miles
anybody who sells that on a saturday
on this now look when i go to work on a
saturday i'm going to kill you i'm going
to snook coke uh-huh i don't just don't
want one ram i need an 8-ball i need my
dick sucked i need a couple coco locos
that red robin i need to buy the
bartender a shot i got a chance there
i'm going for the short nickel if you
tell me that if i could sell that table
i get 500 even if i sell it at cost
just to get it out of here if tom segura
comes in he goes i want to picture
charles bronson even though i got a
picture of charles bronson right there
i'm going to sell him that [ __ ] table
anybody who comes in hi i'm looking for
a truck
let me show you this [ __ ] car right
now but it's not a truck it's beautiful
you give a [ __ ] what it is you want a
deal right i can sell you that for cars
let's take a look at people go i came in
here for a super wagon you'd show me and
said i don't give a [ __ ] it's my world
i would sell you that [ __ ] sedan
that's a salesman that's that's what you
know that's what you [ __ ] do i would
i wouldn't pound it i just tell that's
the car for you and i make a driver once
they drive it i got you 50
really my job is to push the envelope
make you drive you don't drive the car
you're not going to buy it
if i drive it
boom that's down number one number two
once you fill out that credit app i got
you but i never let you fill out the
credit
i always took it from you and asked you
questions
because by asking you questions you're
devouring me your [ __ ] information
plus i offer you a water
so it's a psychological game by offering
you that water now you owe me something
back
once we take the ride i go is that terms
we could do yes there are i go inside i
got a credit app and i get a [ __ ]
foursquare most most [ __ ] idiots will
just give you the credit up and say you
fill this up you're dead i fill it out
so now you gotta get you involved and
now i got you under the spell i'm just
asking you questions what's your address
what's your mother's maiden name so yeah
but she's a russian jew you know
whatever the [ __ ] you're gonna tell me
what's your shoe size i got you it's
just a trance
that's what my the last car i bought the
guy filled it out for me yeah aren't you
like right now ready to [ __ ] fill one
out for him yeah you're dealing with
here you want me you want me to teach
you how to do this i'm ready to buy it
like i get that [ __ ] pen
i get that pen
right yeah i get that pen
go lee what are we doing today
okay well i like to buy the super the
subaru cost eighteen thousand dollars
i need ten percent
deposit today that's eighteen hundred
dollars
what payments would you like a month on
i was looking for two
uh
50 250
and what's the term what do you what do
you got you got a car yeah i got a 62
[ __ ] lebaron that's worth three on
loans right
right so here you go
the car is 18
i need 1800 how much down do you have i
have a thousand we'll take it you just
committed to a thousand i got you for a
thousand all right boom sign right there
uh what do you want to make a payment
i'm like 250. so if i get your card for
250
a month you'll buy yeah boom sign right
there you got a car deal boom i come
back and i pound you
all right by the way the 250 is for
[ __ ] 19 years
18 000
my boss said i looked at your credit app
i need 3 000 down because that's profit
i'm always they're always going for down
payment okay that's profit that's their
price so don't do down payment a nickel
necron to that get it done i got good
credit what's the down payment for
nickel into debt give them 10 percent
but nickel into debt boom
you know what do you want to pay a month
to family boom boom 250. all this [ __ ]
is i'm trancing you and i'm confusing
you this is a confusion right here so
three thousand three hundred against my
eighteen thousand well can't you give me
a little more my mother-in-law's a swami
and she said my car is worth twelve
hundred i'll give you fifteen who gives
a [ __ ] i got i got i owned the car for
14 eight
so i got 3 100 in it correct so i got 3
100 you won 11 for your [ __ ] so
so if i give you 11 for your car
you got a deal yeah i just made two
thousand dollars right
jesus so when you go watch the financing
yeah so when i used to work in new york
i used to get a piece of the financing
so i would work you for financing oh so
you don't pick people in cash i get like
a point of the financing if you finance
twenty thousand dollars at ten percent i
get a half a [ __ ] point plus you need
insurance
i know this guy i'm coming down here
sell your insurance
at the end of the week that guy brings
me an envelope for 300 for getting you
an insurance with him because you need a
binder you just moved here from boston
yeah you need to buy them you're buying
them it's free
so when you go in to buy a car now
you're just like listen i know all the
like or do you just like it's all the
same it's all the same
whether you're selling a car a boat a
house a prostitution it's all the same
you could be a puerto rican and go in
and go hey i'm gonna sell you my [ __ ]
it's hundred dollars and 125 around the
world that you could go listen
let me tell you something i gotta suck
my [ __ ] his tongue turned [ __ ]
purple was so [ __ ] good all right my
[ __ ] i shave it three times a day
just in case that crop pops back up
my titties nobody's ever sucked them but
for tonight for you because i like it
because you're jewish
but the package is 300
and you're gonna go why did i pay 300 to
this [ __ ] that just charged me 125 down
the corner
it's amazing that's why i always sell
people you run into a sale
yeah you run into a [ __ ] salesman
that's it that's great everybody learned
something today let me give some shout
outs you know how we dropped knowledge i
can't man we got time to [ __ ] i don't
want you people going out there and
taking for your money you gotta learn
[ __ ] you got any problems email
me
what's up what's the email beauty and
the beast whatever the [ __ ] it is i'll
just go to joeys.net just go to
joeydears.net and email me thompson girl
put the text away tell
tell dave becky you called him back
i want to give a shout out to miguel
popeye barrow
gus
casanova
tom g cody today oh dc smitty
tom heater and my main man [ __ ] bergy
always showing up with an armenian
[ __ ] present for me and i'm saying
talk to me from oh [ __ ] it's monday we
had to do something to my mother
i was playing a little music for my
mother on monday
for the spirits that's nice that's good
who wants to finish this brownie what
are we doing we can't wait i'm not doing
that
i like it
so are you nervous about tomorrow joey
do i look [ __ ] nervous
i don't know you see nerves here
i gotta be honest with you when tommy
was struggling before i got a little
nervous why i just uh thought about it
it just hit me that i was going to
surgery in uh
six or seven hours you know
and it's uh well you know just a little
yeah for a guy like me it just takes
away your breath for a minute but i'll
be fine no big deal
you're going to their professionals you
know medicine's a lot different than
what it was 30 [ __ ] years ago i mean
they do this [ __ ] now you know this guy
is the raiders doctor i'm his last
surgery for the year really for the year
that's it and then you express pages
beyond college
oh right so yeah on sunday nights
when you can when you see them getting
off like you see [ __ ] johnny you see
the guy getting johnny what's his name
johnny football
yeah when he goes in the general
president goes
get the two jews down to the situation
listen we got [ __ ] three we got three
million a year investing in this [ __ ]
menu yeah
i got three million investing in this
manuka and he's [ __ ] lifting off game
number three get the [ __ ] two jews
down there
and they come down you're like oh
the two jews come in there look at your
arm it's broken call upstairs it's
broken when can we do it uh monday at 8
a.m too late this guy i got three
million of them he's gonna heal by next
[ __ ] week
and then they gotta break the news to
you all right the president so can i go
back to kentucky i'm gonna go to my
family doctor that's negative negative
negative as a matter of fact you know
what cause we [ __ ] own you we own you
you're you're in the route right now
they're prepping your [ __ ] bed right
now but i want to hug the kid there you
go kids
we're the jews when they send us a tall
loaf it's like the next is the wolf and
they just shoot you
so you either come with us peacefully or
they send [ __ ] uh you know
and you go and they cut you that night
they cut you monday morning that's what
he does monday morning a knee a shoulder
a neck
by sunday night they already assess the
situation they're calling the hospital
going we need the jew we need the jews
we got nine [ __ ] we got nine [ __ ]
savages that all weigh over 300 pounds
coming in for knees
necks
arms elbows and you go from an elbow to
a foot and by tuesday everybody's all
right by [ __ ] friday you're jumping
up and down and by the next week they
got eating bananas and protein shakes
and you're back out there dog they don't
give a [ __ ] about your helmet
they don't that's pro football right he
doesn't have he was telling me he can't
he's been working for him for 30 years
he goes there's only one guy that's
scarier needles than you a lot of lies
later he goes that guy used to cry
because i saw him cry one time before i
bled that
he cried and he then he became the
steroid guy you should because i'm
telling you i can't [ __ ] do it
tomorrow you can't do needles no the
only thing i'm dreading tomorrow is the
intravenous the iv yeah don't stick it
in my hand but i tell them earlier
there's no [ __ ] i laugh every time i
get blood drawn i laugh really hard wow
it's just an automatic
uh response it's the only thing i'm
serious like that i can think of
in the world like in in life that has
ever done that to me where as they put
it in
and
start taking out i start getting super
giddy like like it's like a weird way of
of it i think it's just my way of
adapting to seeing the blood come out i
totally i look at it i started laughing
like a maniac yeah i look at it and i'm
saying a [ __ ] nightmare really but
i'm good now like last week i went to
the uh pre-op
like to me that was the toughest thing
of this whole physical was the pre-op so
i went to whatever you want one of these
no you keep looking like something's
there merely on pop one no or not oh man
to experiment on the way home anyway i
went to the pre-op they did the all this
they touched the balls the back the
x-rays the ekg then he goes you gotta do
a piss test and go get blood
even though i trust these people i still
get that little scared for a minute and
then she comes and gets me right away i
thought she just want to sit down and
[ __ ] no i'm gonna lay down i always put
santana on
the foo fighters i always gotta have
them too the film fighters yeah the one
song
best of you gotta have it on
and she comes in she dumps the bed down
a little bit
and they rub the the kids stuff and they
get the kid's needle all right i'm like
i know i tell them just get the kids
and get the liquid cocaine from the back
not the [ __ ] you give with the russians
i want the good [ __ ] they come in they
rub it she ties my arm i look the other
way i breathe i prepare myself i just
breathe
it's that needle when it gets slipped in
if the needle gets slipped on like a
savage i'm going down really yeah but if
they just there's times there's some
women out there that you don't even feel
it
i feel it after a minute i feel
a little light-headed and then by the
time i even i'm breathing i feel the
strap come off that means you're done i
feel like going like that with my arm
and by that time i'm just
the music and i'll take it off like
you're a bad [ __ ]
because i didn't feel dick
yeah and i used to faint at night like
when i thought i had the blood clot in
my leg i went to the hospital i took
bladder and faint at night
went out so it's been very good the last
year how about catheters have you ever
had that in like for oh i just did a
colonoscopy august 4th and it was
nothing again i felt the needle a little
bit it was just hot man when i was
hospitalized like years ago when i have
a deed yeah that's right uh
you wake up and everything's right you
don't remember them putting anything in
so i had a catheter in
but i didn't it was fine i didn't feel
anything but a nurse tripped over the
tube
and i was like
like i screamed i was like what does she
end up because she goes it's not
supposed to go like that that was her
apology i was like what and she was like
yeah i stepped on it that's why it like
yanked on you
it was the [ __ ] most painful thing
and her way of handling was just
not supposed to go that way i think i
knew that
i don't like any of that [ __ ] i deal
with it because uh it's a part of life
you can't yeah
you know
how was colonoscopy
the colonoscopy the milkshake of death
you [ __ ] was heavy duty
but i prepared myself i ate fruit the
whole week you know i i high fiber stuff
i tried to push out the existing stuff i
sweat a lot
i you know yeah you got to take care a
lot of oatmeal you know a lot of apples
so when i drank the first potion it
loosened me up the second one they say
is the worst one
it's like tasting the drink is [ __ ]
horrendously bad but if you put limeade
in it
and mix it up what's that [ __ ]
uh
the they get the the pirates called the
powder that they put in water
liquid whatever lemonade whatever the
[ __ ] it is it's not bad you drink it and
you get down there the needle i felt it
in my hand i told you i felt it i got
hot it took me a while to get my
temperature back
and then they put you out and you wake
up and they give you a [ __ ] folder to
go
and when you're looking at just pictures
of your [ __ ] they give you a camera
they show you the camera from beginning
to end you show your [ __ ] wrapped up
the camera going into the [ __ ] and
the tubes and everything and testing
pretty interesting man it's uh
hey listen i'm 51 years old you got to
do it i'm very lucky yes
i know people my age already that i went
to school with and stuff they're either
not here
or they've had long stays in high
schools which
it's mind-boggling you gotta go every
year to this stuff man get these tests
done at your age i'm saying yeah yeah
something you said still scares me i saw
it again today because right before i i
started working out and stuff you said
like you gotta let your blood drain
through your legs and ever since then i
keep seeing really big guys with like
the permanent bruises and like the like
the skin eating away on their on their
it's a horrific thing i was i was there
with my girlfriend at the grocery store
this dude was walking around didn't even
have pants on here just gym shorts and
was picking up bags of of ladies chips
with his legs literally rotting away and
i was like what
is happening you see it all the time
where you want to go like why is it okay
for you to show me that like where these
these dudes have like it's their their
leg is like a tree trunk yeah where
there's no and there's no like it's all
the same size from [ __ ] his thigh to
his ankle and there's like these crazy
open bloodlines yeah open sores
you know how i work to get my ankle that
skinny
yeah
i do the same [ __ ] every night dude you
work i get on my ass yeah pop my legs up
yeah i split i do a v i can [ __ ] v on
the wall now because i've been doing it
i pick my legs up i creep i go to the
side i suck all this in but i do the
other side and that helps to go to the
bathroom that's good for your digestive
tract cleans your kidneys it's yoga [ __ ]
but the best move is your feet up
because the blood goes down
and now it gets processed instead of
getting purple on your [ __ ] feet yeah
you know if you don't do nothing if you
put your feet up and watch [ __ ]
daytime football or [ __ ] day and he
chips that blood ain't going nowhere how
do you go like vertical on them like i
go vertical the whole thing those are
all yoga how long you have to hold that
for 10 minutes and then you just let it
drop and breathe and the more
uncomfortable you breathe through the
pain
and you breathe the pain away and you
breathe and every day you'll get more
and more flexible
but you're getting that blood to go down
and then you put your feet on and you do
bridges and all that [ __ ] to help i
my main purpose of acupuncture is to
open the chakras and to keep that blood
going you know the way i read it was
they smoke more in china that they do
here the reason why they stay alive is
tai chi and the acupuncture
the cancer rate is lower in china
because the [ __ ] the the circulatory
it's very important
that's the number one thing you know i
have friends that they're [ __ ] uh
their ankles and that's the first sign
of anything that's it that's that's the
first [ __ ] sign the ankle these
people you see at the airport walking
around for you you want to grab them are
you [ __ ] serious you said i saw one
with a tattoo i don't know what it is
with people with fat [ __ ] legs that
are purple putting that parrot on there
like that's gonna throw you off that
money you spent for the ink you could
have spent the 24 hour fitness for a
[ __ ] trainer you know so you got your
fat friend saying it's a cool parrot
look at your [ __ ] vein wait till the
parrot blows his head blows the [ __ ] up
it's amazing it's [ __ ] amazing yeah
that's my main thing of going to
acupuncture my insurance covers it so i
gotta go they don't cover all the visits
you know what i'm saying yeah i work
something out with that's why for my
circulation that's because you have to
you know what my ankles were like when i
was 4 18 i did the longest yard you were
4 18. i did the longest shot i was 4
[ __ ] 18 right there jesus look at my
stomach look at look at that laying down
it was a foot away from me i gotta go
look closer laying down there was a foot
up in the air really i couldn't breathe
right there that scene was killing me
right there at that point at that point
i already had the sleep apnea but even
the machine wasn't really helping me i
was sleeping six hours a night a lot
better than what i was doing
but i read up and that's the whole thing
is that that sleep apnea doesn't bring a
lot of blood to all your parts so people
have sleep apnea they say they have a
higher thing of getting cancer yeah i
was like [ __ ] it i'm gonna go to
acupuncture and get everything clear get
those chakras open get those blood veins
going that's so important to me
do you know how many times i do it in
the daytime i just hang my feet up on
the wall you put your ass
to the wall your ass has to so you have
to just snick on there and then flip
over and put your feet up and just leave
them there put the tv on and just leave
it
it's a great [ __ ] movie i'm not a
yoga teacher i just i'm just some fat
[ __ ] that's trying to learn how you
doing lisa what do you got going on
we're gonna we're gonna do another show
wednesday night at eight o'clock show
post [ __ ]
surgery i'm still going are you gonna do
it then really post surgery
you're an animal i'm doing the surgery
yeah tomorrow night i'll sleep like a
baby i got these things i got a couple
vodka martinis i'm going to bring some
of these [ __ ] over and give me a
little wednesday
wednesday i'll get a good night's sleep
i got to take a puerto rican shower
oh it'll be disgusting for how long
until i get the stitches out how long is
that thursday morning
yeah that's it
[ __ ] thursday morning 10 15 the stitches
go on the way home i go to luca lake
sign up for
the [ __ ] physical therapy from there
i go to y i'm saying do five minutes on
the bike and it's on after that after
that you're gonna see like rocky
drinking [ __ ] eggs running on [ __ ]
the street here like a savage
i don't wanna hear no excuses what's up
with you what's what's going on with you
tell me something i'm doing my [ __ ]
pods you know doing my shows so
she's great she's great i'm so savage
she's a savage she's hitting the road
every every all the time almost every
week and then
we're doing our podcast and you know
just trying to make trying to [ __ ]
put the pieces together yeah dude same
thing you look good thanks buddy i'm
going to hong kong we're going to do the
that comedy festival so that should be
hong kong comedy festival yeah who's
doing it with you uh the shaman has pete
lee and chad daniels talk about your
wife you don't go to hong kong it's not
going to hong kong no type of [ __ ]
pimp
that's how you take your wife to hong
kong no because the schedule is crazy we
were going to do it and then the
schedule came out and it's like once
we're there we're on planes
and it's a week so it'd be like hong
kong a day singapore which is a
four-hour flight another day or two
there fly back it's not like
hey enjoy hong kong for
a week it's plain another plane a ferry
another i mean it's like
i don't think it's very chill or
conducive to i want to go for like uh
yeah yeah proper rest are you going to
hong kong where's my time with don come
on i've never been a hug be [ __ ]
thankful
thanks for having me dude thank you for
having me here
your [ __ ] family i've been calling
you for two years
two years you've been saying times a
girl get a mom when we got his wife lisa
[ __ ] 48 hours of i mean like i i mean
i'm on the road right now too much
going to try to change i'm i am changing
it
like it's starting in november
this weekend that normally works right
then the festival then september 18th
i'm doing the fort lauderdale one night
only christina and i together okay so
you're flying down and coming right back
no i'm going to stay there a week hang
with the family then orlando improv and
then i do a bunch of like one-nighters
and stuff the rest of the year doug i'm
on the same [ __ ] i'm rehabbing this
leg this thing swaps september 18th brea
new york denver yeah
portland but the key with you you and
you i always see this with you and
that's what i'm trying to do more of is
you'd like you have your
your absolutes like you're not doing
sunday and you're not going to like do
you're going to take your break if you
want it you need you know that's the
important thing to do i think is you got
to like plan it out plan out [ __ ] more
you know what i mean so i'm not 28.
right i want to give you this best show
possible
i want to give you the best that i could
be
if i'm tired or my leg hurts and it's
hard to get i'm thinking about something
else i'm not going to give you the best
show i can
on a saturday night i'm not thinking
about nothing else i'm frightened i'm
not thinking about now it's on a
thursday i'm not thinking about none of
those on a sunday i'm thinking about my
family yeah i'm thinking about how i
should have dinner with my family that's
what family's [ __ ] doing i love going
home on the side but no i gotta sit here
and do a show for 85 [ __ ] people
because the club owner said last sunday
they were [ __ ] packed we had a bunch
of reservations so i kept you over
listen in july and august no more you're
not gonna do tickets no more
joe had a great weekend in denver that's
joe and denver yeah the majority of
comics right now anywhere where there's
cold weather people don't want to be put
in the [ __ ] building now until
september people in buffalo
syria those people yeah it's gonna be
much slower for sure you know so there's
a reason for that i'm not out to waste
nobody's [ __ ] time i want to give you
the best possible show i can give you i
will wake up early at three o'clock and
get on the plane lee knows this
everybody knows this about me we bumped
into airports before oh yeah but i want
to be rested you know and 10 years ago
you come see me and you get a guy that
hadn't slept in three [ __ ] nights
yeah
two from doing blow and one tonight from
doing radio the first night you get
there you live in l.a you're in [ __ ]
miami
the first night you're on a three-hour
difference you know even if you don't do
blow you're just sitting there till five
and they're picking you up at six to do
radio because you usually go to la to
sleep but two that's the crazy thing
that people don't understand is how
tired you are you're [ __ ] tired yeah
i mean like all if you do the road week
after week after week i i've only i've
gone with joey like two times
and just we usually do the podcast
wednesday mornings until recently and
then joey takes the we are i i i was
with you at like 3 30 a.m going to lax
and then the next day is radio and then
with you it's not like you have an easy
night you know i'm getting stoned as
[ __ ] up late and then you take the 7
a.m flight back so it's i was exhausted
after
one week of doing it it's tough and you
know
i'm going to houston and doing wednesday
through sunday and doing blowing doing
three mornings
man you have no [ __ ] idea and you're
blowing up you're eating sodium
and you're just blowing up on the
[ __ ] road you're drinking beer you
you're smoking cigarettes you're smoking
pot i mean it's just amazing and don't
they give like in vegas like a monday
this sunday
like isn't it like it's a week it's a
[ __ ] nightmare that is the worst it's
it's a long [ __ ] week
it's too long of a week for for for me
at this age
i cannot do it i can't give the people a
decent show why would i want to do that
bring me one uncle if you don't mind oh
thank you brother i got it
and that's why
i opt to do that i want to do the
podcast on mondays and wednesdays
i want to go to jiu jitsu monday and
wednesday yeah i want that option you
know i want to
i have a schedule i cannot be i i've
lived in this town for 17 years the road
is a great place for a comedian
but i see where
when you get you know because you don't
know
the agents are just calling you and
going oh i got you this date guess what
guess who called yeah and here you are
and you're doing six in a row
six in a row you don't want to hear that
joke ever again
you don't want to true you you don't
trust me i'm telling you i did what
seven went this year i went on a run
this year from march to april i did
eight weeks or something seven weeks
yeah i thought you got up to ten yeah
just to really try and it was
driving down lax every week is [ __ ] a
lot after on wednesday doing two
podcasts a week at six in the morning so
i had to revamp it i'm moving the
podcast
later now you know tomorrow i usually be
leaving on a thursday well today's
monday i usually be leaving on thursday
morning so
so that's how we do it just to give them
the better show so i'm in better shape
three weeks for the road he knows you
know and especially what he's doing
wednesday through sunday by friday
you're about to [ __ ] kill yourself
thank god we have the debt squad people
that come to the shows and it makes it a
little easier saturday is a great day
i'm excited as [ __ ] saturday saturday i
know it's all debt squad i know i'm
gonna [ __ ] go out there and whatever
i say we're gonna take him on a journey
and we're gonna get paid and we're going
to plan we're going to leave that sunday
when you wake up from that high
even if you don't do blow when you wake
up from saturday night two shows to
sunday
and you call the club at four you watch
you slip to 10
your nfl comes on you know it's horrific
you watch both [ __ ] games
and then you call the club and go hey
how are we doing knowing we have 88
tickets left but you're going to do
great walking
i'm [ __ ] tired it's time to go yeah
then you put on cnn there's a [ __ ]
rainstorm coming your way
and you're leaving you know no there's
ways to do this yeah i take a hit by
leaving at seven o'clock in the morning
sunday but i'm in my bed by 11
and that's it's a straight journey it's
the most important thing if i dice a
dilly dally let me take the two o'clock
oh i know you learned what the [ __ ] are
you gonna do in a hotel room until two
o'clock your day is gone you're gonna
land here at sixth 405. good luck
get the [ __ ] out of it get the food
gives a [ __ ] you're in your house at 12.
and i saved time i saved aggravation
that's what it's all about when you're
coming because not being [ __ ] not
accurate it's true
no man you're the best hit me with
something time you know you drop
something out you got the cuban beard
got the fidel look you know
you show up with no [ __ ] sayings no
sayings you ever have a question that
really [ __ ] with you and i shouldn't
[ __ ] with you like last night i was just
i was watching sportscenter before bed
and then i went to mike trout and i said
would you rather hit a home run or would
you rather steal a home run like
take it away from somebody and for some
reason i got in my head like it it
decides what kind of person you are like
if you want to be a go-getter or if you
just want to and it [ __ ] with me for
like hours like i couldn't come up with
an answer if i wanted to hit a home run
or steal a home run and i wasn't high
and i i don't know why it [ __ ] with
me for so long
and i have no idea how to answer it do
you have like a prophet you have like a
student's notebook listen like there's a
[ __ ] have you ever got your own that's
the point you know the [ __ ] chocolate
that's i've been telling you this for
years if you eat that chocolate
questions like that you want to look at
that [ __ ] and go you know what
go [ __ ] yourself espn let's start off
with alex you got to take some if you
took alpha brainly you wouldn't think
about it i wouldn't care about this
question who gives a [ __ ] well i want to
home run i gotta take you watch too much
esp i've been telling you that since i
met you
more [ __ ] and less what is that again
more reading [ __ ] and less espn more
push-ups and less espn it's [ __ ] your
mind up making your mind the moist talk
to this [ __ ] guy hey man
stop it i know you watched just as much
as you were high last night were you not
a a little bit at the end unbelievable
this is why you got to go home are you a
big sports center guy yeah it just it
replays and then there's nfl live and
that's gonna watch what's in the 12th i
know when i call him we don't i'm done
i'm looking at steve's in my own cd he's
watching sportszone
he sits there all day and he gives a
[ __ ] like
he watches the clock and they talk and
game shows and you believe everything
stefan whatever says about the nba you
[ __ ] get up
together whatever his name is the black
guy oh that guy's annoying as hell oh
he's pissing everybody off anyway
for maximization optimization all right
on it they ain't [ __ ] around over
there right
some people they got one a day and all
these [ __ ] [ __ ] things that don't do
dick for you iron improves who you are
it improves it makes you be the best you
could [ __ ] be if you're a kid and you
want to go back to college you want to
read you want to stay up all night you
have to take meth like the rest of these
[ __ ] jerk-offs take some
take some an alpha brain don't take me
out alpha brain will make you [ __ ]
focus i'm telling you two alpha brains
you're up and [ __ ] hopping in fact my
alpha brain strike will start to get on
monday after the surgery because i'm
home for four weeks i got to write a
bunch of material so i'm gonna focus you
know what go to honor.com and look at
everything they got they got something
for you whether it's strong bone whether
it's [ __ ] uh shroom tech whether it's
the [ __ ] enzymes or mango enzymes
whether it's a thing that you go like
that and you get your muscles they got
kettlebells they got everything on it
what's your code word go to on it what's
the code word church church and get ten
percent off while you're there
stay on it stay on it get it sent to
your house on the first like a real
human being you got to go to store and
order it just stay on it first time you
sign up for standing at 20 off that's
how i roll here what do you put in the
box church like a bad [ __ ] that
you are c-h-u-r-c-h
also a shout-out to some of my [ __ ]
best i love you [ __ ] hulu plus
you can watch hulu plus anytime anywhere
7.99 a month you're saying joey how is
that possible 7.99 a month you can watch
on any streaming [ __ ] device that you
want you understand me on a smart tv
roku apple xbox pretty much any if it
streams you're [ __ ] watching hulu
plus that's how we work listen if you
watch a commercial with hulu plus
they're gonna
give you what league they're gonna give
you two weeks that's it uncle joey we go
a step further here in the church what's
happening now if you put
joey in the box j-o-e-y you get two
weeks for free and 7.99 a [ __ ] month
so [ __ ] the 7.99 a month ain't doing no
favors when you run with uncle joey you
get two weeks for free
huluplus.com they don't [ __ ] around
smart tv roku
apple
7.99 a month i'm offering my listeners
two weeks on the arms gratis you know
why because that's how we roll all right
don't [ __ ] get carried away here i
love you guys hulu you know what shows
they got let me show you
the daily show family guy i want to
marry harry gang related grow up fisher
america's got talent last night was seth
myers they got southpaw did you know
about south park they are keeping up
with the kardashians everybody hates
chris [ __ ] spongebob
they got everything yo
that's how we do it huluplus.com
why are you standing online like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] when you can just go to
dollar shave club for a dollar six
dollars or nine dollars a month nine
dollars a month nine times ninety how
much you got a year one over a year and
you got raises sent right to your
[ __ ] house you go there you stand
online you gotta smell some arab his
armpit smells like onions and [ __ ]
lime and you gotta stand there and pay
20 bucks for three [ __ ] raises no
more i'm gonna give you a year raises a
dollar six dollars and nine dollars a
month and the
what are they pressing the box you get
me all my
church church church
and you get a dollar six dollars or nine
dollars dollar shave club that's how
they roll
all right hello
let me tell you something i love
when i got a product that i could
[ __ ] sell
and push it to you people correctly
i love hit esig.com i love these
[ __ ] this cigar right now rocks
they're cigarettes rock you looking to
quit smoking
they got 0 8 16 and 24 milligram
cigarettes for you to quit smoking on
your own [ __ ] pace all right let's
say you want to smoke a cigar you want
to blow in somebody's face you don't
want to light it and turn it off you buy
one of these right now
um blow that right your [ __ ] face
just like that
go to hit esig.com
you understand me go there right now the
proof is in the e-cig smooth 1200 hits
per [ __ ] cigar cigarette better
tasting and they last longer if you go
to hit e6.com go to the box and press
joey's church are you [ __ ] kidding me
or what joey's church you get 20 off
your first door that's how we roll
twenty percent off your first order we
ain't [ __ ] around down here at ev6
hit e6.com my men ed wagaba i love this
[ __ ] making it happen down there
so again onyx.com huluplus.com
dollar shave
and hit e6.com
support us all right don't [ __ ] around
that's it it's a beautiful show it's a
beautiful night it's ten o'clock people
i gotta go it's one o'clock on the east
coast people sitting there like much
watching this go to bed that's why you
almost got fired cox i go to bed
i love you guys stay black thompson girl
you're in denver at the comedy works
thursday wednesday through sunday no
thursday after saturday thursday through
saturday finally you know i ain't
working on like a [ __ ] they got them
in the cave like a south
africa they got them in there like
[ __ ] black people with [ __ ] ebola
picking diamonds till you die
i love you to death
where can they find it i'll go in a
bunch of places just they're all at
tomsegura.com thomas.com support the
podcast your mom's having my mom's house
where they find their mom's house yes
everywhere your myselfpodcast.com always
a pleasure to have you
just see you you're one of my favorites
that's why i wanted you live no [ __ ]
you want to finish this no you and the
[ __ ] you want to take this
what do you want to do to close it out
buddy
something from black sabbath volume four
how about the volumes
under the sun let's see how that [ __ ]
starts off no let's go super night these
people like supernova let's give them
supernova s-u-p-e-r-n-a-u-t
super naught volume four a tremendous
[ __ ] album they did four albums two
albums in four years for the greatest
albums i didn't even know about this
this kid mauricio gave me a book at the
comedy store
wait what are we doing we're defining
this calling one of those
yeah
what are we [ __ ] doing i don't know
oh and you have a special on netflix i
do yes you do yes completely normal on
netflix if you have it
please watch it
now that the show's over don't forget to
sign up for your free trial of hulu plus
hulu plus lets you binge on thousands of
hit shows anytime anywhere on your tv pc
smartphone or tablet support this
podcast and get an extended free trial
of hulu plus when you go to huluplus.com
joey or just go to joeydiaz.net and
click on the hulu plus banner don't
forget to sign up for
dollarshaveclub.com get high quality
razors sent to your door every month for
a fraction of what you pay at retail now
go to dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash church or just go to
joeydiaz.com